we'll divide you guys up into five
sections so we get five topics everyone
gets a fair go then we'll drop a beat my
band will do that and we'll do a
Freestyle right no not quite yet not my
gosh
section here suggestion number one what
would you like a rap about
sanitation
from your demeanor and accent I imagine
you work for the dsny is that correct
good nah
what do you not what do you work as
A Sign Guy what one of the [__]
you make them you make the signs that
they spin yeah [__] cool I love that
you were just it's just you said
sanitation like you look down on them
and I think if someone in here Works in
sanitation they look down on sign guys
I I respect sign guys they uh I knew
that was a job until now yeah Sign Guy
great
sanitation fantastic let's come to uh
this this half of the middle of the room
watch like a rap about
this is a design guy
[Applause]
so the first part of the rap is is a rap
battle between sanitation and sign guys
thank you
right and then what was the one from
here
you said you said mayonnaise
okay I mean I said no food or animals
but technically it's a condiment so I
will accept that
some people just reacted as if they're
like it's not a condiment Chris it's a
food stuff and I will accept that it's
possibly not a condiment it's more it's
got more nutritional value than ketchup
okay mayonnaise sign guys versus
sanitation
um
okay I heard Hooters yeah and then and
then what was the last night one
okay cool the woman who said the Irish
do you want to start another of the many
wars that have happened
between my people and their people
okay the last time I went to the doctor
but we'll combine it we'll make it the
last time I went to Hooters that will
work um
it was in Clearwater Florida
uh people in this section of the room
you see you said the clap thank you very
much for admitting that
um
and the British Monarchy thank you for
clarifying the British Monarchy
uh you know Norway's got one as well
um
okay so the British Monarchy the clap my
last visit to Hooters mayonnaise and
sanitation versus Sign Guy
um right those those are your topics
this is this is going to be a rap about
them the rap will be as good as the
topic so if you don't like it it's your
fault
[Laughter]
um
to my lovely band I would love if you
could produce some of your musical
Wizardry
um they they make up the beat as well
it's entire this is entirely made up
it's gonna be great I'm thoroughly
excited can't wait
all right
[Music]
okay let's have some fun and we'll start
of course with this
me oh my starter fight tonight looking
at the Sign Guy I see you from the side
saying he's a fine guy oh my caught my
eye it decided the road making sure
everyone knows where they can go
painting all the letters none better is
so defined on the sign yeah you'd be
sweating on your back put it on enamel
ringing it hard like the liquid in the
flannel but guys sat over there feeling
frustration he says this guy's shouting
out sanitation why is he trying to diss
US yeah I'll pursue you come down here
we be dwelling in the sewers underneath
the manhole where we go watching out for
[__] and the piss that flows cleaning
all of this I'm glad you asked yeah it
smells like ass but we removed the trash
we wear the green uniforms white logo
you see the little snake moving round
the pole it's not the doctor's one
that's the logo of dsny Sign Guy may be
aimed so high he points up and says I
painted you suck sanitation guys like
I've got a huge truck you can and get
[__] Amber's so nice over here yes my
advice ever since I was a young guy a
tiny wee kid my mom's like keep the
mayonnaise inside the fridge but one
time I ignored that advice I left it out
for two weeks it didn't taste nice
because the eggs aren't shelf stable you
gotta keep it chilled down then you were
able to put it inside the sandwich and
yes please I recommend it on the outside
of a grilled cheese it makes the cross
sold Brown make sure you use a spatula
to hold it down get the cheese going
over side share it with your friends the
best cheese for melting that would be
American second best is cheddar but
mayonnaise off my head I get my canola
oil mix it with the eggs you can make
your owns if you chose me bougie
mayonnaise I might call it aioli aioli
people over here thinking back within a
dream you profit up the doctor you
raised your hand say in Ireland but one
guy you understand he loves the lovely
ladies with the big bosoms he walks into
the bar he's like we could be cousins it
doesn't matter I wanna have a squeeze in
your jugs the last time I went there I
had a [__] good time I was doing all
the shots ladies bringing them up they
were shimmy in their Bots the white on
the top the little orange short shorts I
think that's still the uniform this was
before covid maybe they had to wear
masks as long as I could see the tits
and the ass the T and the a look at
right that moving over here monarchy
you're slinging it back I presume we
used to own you at some time and sold
your shout out like no queen of mine
with that little finger that you held up
apologies I do not endorse the British
Monarchy I'm not a republican I wish
they'd go away that they're in the
palace every day well not the queen
anymore because she sadly died and when
she died you were like yes we're filled
with pride oh hooray she's gone today
probably you did the dance upon her
grave you laughed and you laughed you
couldn't help yourself and now you're
like come on King Charles come down in
your health I hope you fall down a
sanitation sewer and then you'd see
William and maybe pursue her and say
let's kill all the dogs yes let's call
these picking up knives and stabbing all
the corgis okay maybe that's a bit too
far I hope the Sign Guy in the
sanitation are making it up and
realizing what you think is like you're
good at painting and you stink if you
don't shower well there we go that's
that we're finishing up from the front
to the back freestyle serving up that
wrap the last time I went to Hooters I
caught the clap
[Applause]
thank you very much